some relief for coronavirus long haulers  potentially those are patients who still  battle symptoms months after getting  sick  the group's survivor corps pulled 962  long haulers 39 percent of people felt  their symptoms did improve after getting  the coronavirus vaccine  there's a yale professor who is studying  the long-term effects of the coronavirus  and she is collecting samples to compare  immune responses before and after  long-haulers get the vaccine  the vaccine induces robust antibody and  t cell responses  that can clear the viral reservoir or  remnants  that's causing the inflammation and that  would be a permanent solution to lung  covet  another theory is long-term covet is  driven by a hyperactive autoimmune  response  and the vaccine may reduce those  responses yale hopes to enroll at least  100 people with coronavirus long term  in a study to understand if that relief  from the vaccine will last